people are amazed that these things are
hand-painted the entire time the
painting people are paying attention to
what we're up to when you see us doing
it it's like an unveiling of slow
unveiling wall dogs is a contracting
company that does large-scale
hand-painted ad murals on the sides of
buildings largest we do is almost 24
stories high the larger walls take us
about a week to 10 days to paint we
usually have a deadline to meet so we
work from sunup to sundown
they're only about five companies I
think in this country that still
hand-paint walls the 1990 the entire
industry started changing over to vinyl
computer printed billboards the reason
we're still able to be in business doing
this is the problems with large pieces
of vinyl blowing down and then the
appeal of watching us paint when I first
get the job from the agency we take the
artwork rid that off stick it under our
opaque projector and draw a pattern in
the four by 10 foot increments the
pencil that we use has a current running
through it and burns little holes in the
paper that gives us a image of the ad in
perfect scale we take the paper out on
the job we roll it out on the side of
the wall and rub it with a charcoal bag
and transfer the image through the paper
to the wall itself then we paint from
that in order to make these things come
out photorealistic it takes the skill of
the painter I'm always looking for young
talent I've got one guy Sergio he's like
me when I was young I really wanted to
do this and the worst friend I loved it
and he's like that too I was amazed just
for the size you know and somebody told
me you know those are hand painted and I
was like
no that can have you possible I gotta
get a job over there when you're out
there you don't see what you're painting
you know just being in a big that's
right so every time we come down step
back and see what we did we're gonna
know
I'm supposable we'll see man things
looking good so far
it's been a battle to keep hand-painting
popular but there's kind of a
renaissance right now hand-painted walls
in advertising to me it's just as
fascinating to look at a hand-painted
wall as it is to look at something in an
art gallery I think that adds a little
extra wow factor to the whole thing
you